yeah what is politican saying it's like
comic-con for political dorks
exactly that's exactly correct yeah and
it's weird because what they do Joe is
they invite like like establishment
media figures and some politicians but
then they also invite new media figures
like me and our worlds do not mix yeah
yes in fact many of them I don't even
think many of them knew who I was
meanwhile when you actually go to the
people who were there you know it was
all the new media people who are getting
the most attention right where you have
guys like Bill Kristol walking around
who was in the Bush administration and
people are like who who are you
mmm so it's a very weird you know thing
going on there well kudos to them for
recognizing that new media has such a
place yeah it's just media I mean at
this point I think that yeah this whole
concept of new media versus all be it's
just media yeah there's independent
uncensored untethered media which is why
we're more popular yeah of course yeah
yeah try watching one of those ABC
Nightline or one of those [ __ ]
political shows terrible and then try
watching something on YouTube where
people get to be free with their
language and free with their expression
that beholden to any executives or
producers and yeah so they get it but
they don't get it get it because when I
went to the chris Christie thing they
had it in this giant room and about 25%
of the room was full and then for one of
my debates that I did I did a few panels
but one debate they put me in like the
smallest room and we had all the seats
full and people standing up and packing
the room so they get it but they don't
get it get it they taught to them the
new media people are kind of like
afterthought like okay we'll have them
because you know they should be here but
they don't they don't realize that the
draw is not chris christie the draw is
the new media people well chris christie
and that's not just me but i just wanna
clear up in her anymore he's not I mean
like who is he why would they think that
he we could fill a place because he's
been on TV a lot but I want to be clear
I'm not even just saying Oh left-wing
new media which obviously is what I
would be but even the ben shapiro types
of course he has a big audience when he
comes he's got a giant yes exactly
yeah but it's so it's all the new media
people who are popular and the rest of
them are not